- So, what did you do to keep yourself
like busy during quarantine?
- I planned this.
- Mmhmm.
- So this was like
- You planned it?
- Oh yeah.
I was like doing the tests
and like--
- Yes.
- tracking with all the apps.
I like was like, we're
gonna get this done.
We're going to do it.
- I love it.
- I was so excited,
so that was a mission and--
- Kind of great timing
for artists or actors
because you can't work anyway.
- That was my thought,
I was we're stuck here,
- Yeah.
- Let's, let's do the thing
we always wanted to do
is make a baby.
- Yeah.
- So we did that
and then I did a Christmas album
'cause I was home with my studio
and my brothers they're like,
they produce and wrote like
half these songs with me,
all the originals so--
- Really?
- Yes, it was awesome,
it was a fun time.
So all my early weird pregnancy feelings,
I was singing this whole Christmas album.
(laughing)
- That's, so this wasn't
the plan to do Christmas,
it just was kind of like,
hey, this is perfect timing.
- That's actually awesome.
- It's like always
been the dream because
like, I am Christmas,
my birthday is December 22nd,
my wedding was on that day as well.
- Your birthday gets
trumped every year anyway--
- No, no,
it gets better.
- Just a big celebration.
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- Like,
I always have my
anniversary on my birthdays.
- You're so happy right now.
- I'm so happy, I'm glowing.
- I know, that's really cool.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I'm so happy for you.
It's so awesome.
Well, congrats.
I, I hear you're obviously gonna be mom,
but have you thought of
what songs that you'll sing?
- I do have a song.
I can't believe I'm gonna
say this the first time ever
with Earth, Wind & Fire.
- What!
- On my Christmas album.
- Oh my gosh!
- And we just shot--
- They should let you,
this is a great tease.
- I know right,
I was like I'm allowed to say it.
The track listing will be out I think,
so we did a music video
and I was like my baby's
first music video's
with Earth, Wind & Fire!
Like--
- Oh my gosh.
That's incredible.
- Thank you I'm sweating, I don't know if
I'm allowed to say that.
- The bar is high though.
- Bar's high.
- You're setting the bar high.
- Oops.
(laughing)
- Oh, oops.